looks good really good love for you to
get your masters but we'll talk about
that a shelter now Wow the Michelle
Darnell yes I was her executive
assistant for five years oh I bet you
just have the juiciest stories I'll
check the kids and the bits please well
yeah I mean most of it I can't I can't
talk about but um it was a wonderful
experience and I learned a lot working
for her she is a personal hero of mine
I just she's a she's a special lady okay
she's a very good role model I have a
signed copy this is true story signed
copy of the power of me I kind of
modeled my life personally and
professionally after her - the hair when
I had short hair I like to take a
lesbian but I hope I think we have a lot
in common
do we just stay out of jail
no what no don't say that that's an
awful thing to say would you say that to
her what would she say back just shut up
Claire she well shut up Claire cuz
you're hired
love that let's fill out some paperwork
you've got the job I have the job shut
up Claire you're are hired shut up
Claire is that right
I can't tell if you're doing a bit shut
up Claire you're hired
you shut up Claire cuz you're hired I
got it thank you yes um I'll go find my
paperwork shut up Claire HR go to your
right